-Welcome back to the show.
And thank you for --
-Love you, Burna!
-Yeah, you got
a little love right there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Since you were last on our show,
you won a Grammy.
Congratulations, bud.
-Thank you.
-That's got to feel good.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, since "Love, Damini"
came out this summer,
the song "Last Last"
was number 1
on U.S. Afro Beats
chart for eight weeks.
-Hold on. Say it again.
-"Love, Damini" or --
-No, the "Last Last."
-"Last Last" was number 1 --
-[ Laughs ]
-Oh, come on. Give me a break.
-It's supposed to be
"Last Last."
-Oh, "Last Last."
-Hey!
-Sorry. Not...
-With strength.
-..."Last Last."
-No, there's no strength.
-No strength in that.
-"Last Last."
-Hey!
-Yeah, okay, good.
You're performing "Last Last"
for us later tonight.
-I am.
-You have so many collaborators
on this album.
And I do love J Balvin,
of course.
I know him. Khaled.
Ladysmith Black Mambazo.
And then I see Ed Sheeran.
And I go, "Interesting."
Does he know how to pronounce
"Last Last"?
-Definitely.
-He does, yeah. He does.
What's Ed Sheeran like when you
get in the studio with him?
-Oh, he's amazing, man.
-He's a good dude.
-Yeah, he's like one of
my favorite people
in general in the world,
you know?
-Really?
-Yeah, man.
-How did you guys
come about your song?
-Well, the same way we
come about every other song.
-What?
You just get in the studio?
-Yeah, we just literally get
in the studio,
and then it's just
literally magical.
He has a cheat code, 'cause he
plays the guitar the whole time,
and it's like --
It just makes everything
so much easier, you know?
-Yeah. Where did the name
Burna Boy come from?
-This is weird, but I used to
draw comic books and stuff.
I know I don't look like it.
But, yeah, I used to
draw comic books and,
like, copy, like, you know,
different, like,
"Spider-Mans" and "Superman."
I would just draw it.
And then, at a point,
I wanted my own.
I wanted to be my own superhero,
where I could draw me
as a superhero, you know,
with the cape and all that.
So I was trying to
come up with a name
and all I could think of
was Burna Boy.
-No way.
So that's where Burna Boy
comes from?
-Literally.
'Cause, you know, Spider-Man...
-Yeah, Spider-Man, Burna Boy.
-Exactly.
-Wow! How old were you
when you first started music?
-[ Breathes deeply ]
Like 2.
-A baby.
-Yeah.
Like, I could always make music
and I could always
find my way around music.
-But did you write --
When did you start
really getting into -- 2?
-No, no, not 2.
-No.
-I used to sing "Hip Hop Hooray"
and stuff when I was young.
-Yeah, of course.
Do you remember
your first song that you wrote?
-I remember
it was called "Jump,"
and I said "jump"
a bunch of times.
-Yeah. You said that your music
brings people together
who speak different languages,
just through dance.
And you -- I was
going to ask you to show me
a dance move
that maybe I could do.
If I go to a Burna Boy concert,
I could do it on the stage.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You can teach me how to do it.
Just to spread the love,
so we can all --
Just to spread the love.
-I'm thinking of
an easy one for you.
-Why would you think of
an easy one for me?
You've seen my moves.
-That's exactly why
I'm thinking of an easy one.
[ Laughter, cymbal crash ]
-What can we do?
-Alright. Maybe try this.
I hurt my leg,
so I'm going to --
-Yeah.
♪♪
Alright, here we go.
-So, this one is called --
Well, the fans call it
the Afro Moonwalk.
-Afro Moonwalk.
-Yeah.
So, it's almost like
you're walking.
Like, you're walking forward,
but you're not
really moving, right?
-Uh-huh.
-So, you're gonna go like this.
-Here it goes.
-At least you didn't fall.
-You do it.
I can do it with you.
Alright, go.
Burna Boy, everybody.
Check out his album,
"Love, Damini."
It is out now.
He's performing for us
when we come back.
"Last Last"!
Stick around, everybody.